on est tous les fronts
oui le but d'higuain ligue 1 et de ligue
2 face au no doubt about apart gymnase
au liban se battre
c'est vrai que je l'espère
aujourd'hui dans
je trouve
tu rencontreras vice et
ok
etc
mais bon la corvée d'eau et a produit
devant l'autre et noir ouais bah c'est
bon c'est l'odeur le verre est porté par
moins 30 et trempé je pense que c'est
bon écoute non les deux agents bien
aussi la porte à porte pas ses clés
un copain
louis un ciel qui est super beau de
l'échelle avec un mec même assez les
bateliers hopper nous attend va la paire
belge est tombé en pleurs 600 plants
patrouille qui va le voir d'ailleurs
hâte à gosses veulent voir devraient pas
s'apaiser d'apple juste la date à droite
là ses principes est assez ouvert puis
là ou pas justement le voilà il ya des
outils de plus basses dans ce vaisseau
de la honte ne devrait pas souvent mais
combien savoir les trains en panne a
bloqué jeudi dans là d'écran et pâle et
à bout portant
verts et le répondant quand on écoute le
vert regarde le monde ouvert les galons
de paix du verre c'est incroyable comme
l éclair au départ yarakh loin ce bassin
bouge pas tant que la loi veut on
l'avait bien les balles lundi dans la
baie
m